okay there we go or are we working hey
hey restart the router sorry everyone
oh boy - yeah hi sorry about that
the internet bugged out because it's
been the first time I've tried to stream
for a while and the Internet's been kind
of shitty lately especially considering
the weather also yeah randomly hailed
yes like it randomly hailed like three
days in a row yeah I was really weird
there was really sunny out remember the
golf ball sized hail yesterday would
confuse things crazy no I don't is Josh
in this thing - josh is here hi yes
Joshua you nerd weather doesn't affect
the Internet yeah probably doesn't
depends on if it's like lightning storms
and in like now probably not actually
actually I think Remlinger in their mess
around ones were messing with the wires
yeah you know yeah oh by the way
speaking of speaking of roofing when the
stream cut out Josh and I are doing this
bit about like copyright infringement
and saying that spider-man ps4 stole
spider-man from web of Shadows like holy
[ __ ] dude like we just cracked the case
you know we started laughing so hard but
no one was around to hear or just like
we just did that bit for no one it was
just me and Josh so disappointing holy
[ __ ] rip that meme - dance oh god that
meme could have been something that was
so funny
yeah it was really funny like they stole
spider-man really holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
plain tech gets blown up man's already
know that slayeth non-biological father
I love hearing these quotes over and
over
until I start making them myself Josh
somehow that joke isn't as funny when
you've heard it 30 times anyway look at
the height difference here it's like Tom
Hollands and Mike Colter in real life
are you guys having a seizure
yes Xavier you in college yes so I need
your opinions venom versus the Ultimate
Universe venom who would win but Flash
Thompson is controlling the six one six
am but it was an all caps how could I
avoid it like six times in a row no it's
not annoying when you type it multiple
times in all caps I love it and yeah
yeah everywhere dude it makes us want to
read it more remind me so that way I can
send you messages that way I don't care
you know that's why education really
yeah he's gonna saying he's the nephew
of some famous director so when he got
his a show business he didn't want to be
associated with that it was like a huge
fan changed his last name to cage that's
cultural appropriation okay I need your
opinion who wouldn't who'd win a match
between six one six Obama and universe
four twenty read this please my entire
existence depends on it okay hi Matt gee
you know it's funny I don't want to
address it because there's this
beautiful website so different there are
spells though
you guys should tell people that the
stream is back because people are
immensely confused tell everyone on
Twitter
yeah don't it's not our fault the
internet died but it's your job you got
you guys come fix it
try to get this going I want it it's not
a coin though it's like it's a token
your presses logo I wanted three spider
in boys spiders and these spiders an
alternate universe where Peter Parker is
bullied and called spider-man because
he's weird and eat spiders is he like
that kid I went to school with named
James where if you tell him to eat
anything he'll do it yeah and one time
there is people who told him to eat some
broken glass and I had to hold him back
so he wouldn't do it cuz he has that
little social like awareness is the blue
stripe died into my hair Xavier how it
feels so oh no my spiders I think that's
good six one six venom would win cuz all
time never clicked off you get closer to
the scrolls are you close to the ear see
text return the text to the temple
return the chisel I wouldn't even get
for Xavier Batman versus marine I don't
know why they don't asking my opinion
Xavier you made a moon knight costume
yet yes yes check my Instagram I have an
Instagram now look up Xavier underscore
G mu dou dou Godzilla Mendoza underscore
check it out right now okay okay we're a
link in the in the chat okay whenever
you ask you a question who would the way
your meal who I am though who would win
blank or blank right what's your
definition of wind kill because then
we'll brain there they are but if you
mean beat in a
more traditional sense Batman would be
he just sees it a giant magnet oh my god
like a like a junkyard magnet from
Breaking Bad know he use a wooden one
and then he beat magneto I love that
clip so much that's it that's just it
this is what a real gun oh you got me in
the movies where they just have like
plastic everything so [ __ ] it's to
Xavier what's the name of the school you
go to I'm looking to go to a film school
I'm not comfortable answering I love how
I say I forgot my password and the first
question asked me to reset my password
is to the last word what what's the
point of this [ __ ] then
hey Mason can you put a link to my
Instagram for people in there I'd
appreciate it buddy
yeah I was already on it I'm sorry you
okay I'm not would you rather noodles or
Thanos
but noodles noodles like noodle from
guerrillas noodles or Banco there's this
running joke where no no okay never mind
will not explain it no that's my running
joke owe me money
yeah okay I know it's whatever you
fighting dog the entire audience
pornhub ads say you were five point one
miles away on my youtube channel I I run
an MCU podcast and we only refer to
Thanos sistaco on ironically guys I have
a thing to tell you my ex-girlfriend in
high school like in 10th grade for some
reason one of her friends found her
profile picture on facebook in a pornhub
ad oh it's so uncomfortable and then
sent it to her I was like what's this
and she's like what that's not my name
yeah that shit's scary people just rip
pictures off Google Images cuz yeah
right just look for anybody who looks
like like remotely attractive even
she was very underage when that happened
so I was especially scary yeah dude big
wheel is the main villain of spider-man
ps4 I'm not so down the under Winery oh
you mean okay the Underminer shows up
you spoiler dashes in it [ __ ] off sorry
bro so cool oh I only saw the part where
mr. incredible and Elastigirl
are oh no they are children children
who's that kid the poster don't tell me
don't tell me
spoilers oh god I just hit that guy with
a a little minute that guy even a little
bit more than just lightly injured hey
Xavier I've given you money so you can
play game I couldn't used to buy food
but instead I'm chasing you to play a
[ __ ] video is it dreamer uh-huh I
love you dreamer I'm not playing that
game on purpose because it gives us an
excuse to interact more I love you and
my friend Wow if you keep yelling at me
to play I'm scared that means we get to
still be together but every place
[ __ ] know me yeah no more you have
gone forever after isolated that's why
I'm putting it off is cuz I care so much
about you this girl's gonna bonk you out
of existence dude he's gonna snap his
fingers and then you'll go all over
overused mean and I know you're just
gonna just your head will explode what
what if infinity Wars ending was exactly
the same but everyone's head just
exploded instead Kingsman yeah or no no
like in scanner yo-yo like a really
scary medication rip your [ __ ] we're
gonna talk about it like
everyone's seen infinity that's such a
lie dude I remember people make that
excuse or it's been six months you know
I didn't go out of my way to buy a
[ __ ] ticket I'm sorry what's your
fault
Xavier how hard okay we must rent
another daughter and no caption can we
talk about passive-aggression dollars
features that ending was because like I
honestly thoroughly enjoyed infinity war
up until the end it was fun until the
[ __ ] end because it's such a dumb cop
out you know that all those characters
are gonna come back it's not about the
death though it's about how are they
gonna do it without these characters you
know what I'm saying
yeah it's taking pieces off again why
were there so many sad moments like that
entire scene was just okay okay so you
want tarik ters to die right but you
just want it because the whole point is
so the only goal of fighting they didn't
then then why did they do in the comics
why they do in the comics if the only
point I don't know is oh [ __ ] I thought
they just [ __ ] [ __ ] fix this [ __ ]
because villains never made it it's
interesting to have a villain just
[ __ ] win now are they really [ __ ]
thin we didn't really kind of won did he
in the second one he let me be honest
I've never watched Star Wars he cut off
Luke's hand threw him down an elevator
shaft
but he'll screaming [ __ ] you but he
lived and then he also took his
daughter's boyfriend the only thing
young the only thing that Darth Vader
one was Harrison Ford's somewhat
approval what he won Harrison boy
subdued his Elaine's for believing the
ending was a cop-out he got me damned
he's got ears on the lame you should
[ __ ] go home [ __ ] kill myself Josh
if you go into hiding I won't be
surprised yeah I mean he lives yeah yeah
you're gonna get DOCSIS we think you
don't like infinity waters I mean us at
the dead drop Xavier please answer me
this question why is Gamora
Larry
Brandon's playing again by the way I
gave him the controller a little while
ago that's why it's so [ __ ] yeah
Xavier what's your thoughts I'm Deadpool
- Deadpool - I think is better than the
first one actually and I really
appreciate it the first one is a better
comedy this second one is a better
Deadpool movie the second was a better
movie yes yeah it has a third act I mean
if we referring to it by just comedy -
made me laugh harder but - or one made
me laugh more consistently personally
xavier swain what about the sugar man I
will look up sugar man eventually Xavier
answer this is Brandon key bunker venom
Black Panther died so infinity war is
racist she I'm surprised no one actually
uh nayana Klee said that I'm sure so no
he's answer will you make a video review
on the new ps4 spider-man game maybe no
oh no Grimble Grimble did you come back
to me what happened you see my book no
you Josh what oh oh no oh no no uh rip
PS oh hey it's what happens when you
have a fat ps3 from 2001 eight unlucky
oh oh god these are the this was the
type that [ __ ] died oh wait wait wait
wait I gotta read this comment that I
saw her lose fun
whoa you see the part where Kimura gets
thrown off the cliff was completely
improvised Josh Brolin was so
emotionally involved with this building
merge and so us hit the button on that
oh what a depressing world we live in I
didn't even make the movie weird it's so
hard to press the button on that ps3 is
it really is it a one or is it like a
sensor press F no it's it's full both
what it okay you know it's a sensory
I don't know how I've always had a hard
time turning it on and
oh it's like did they even make infinity
war if everyone was just improvising was
there even a [ __ ] script man
infinity war sucked dude it's [ __ ]
stupid
Brandon you're hurting maybe it wasn't
that it was a cop-out but more that it
was like I said everyone I was I was sat
there with seven other people and
everyone there was like those little
underwhelming if anything if anything
you just felt underwhelming that's wrong
I disagree well you know it wasn't
overwhelming you know what you're
perfectly allowed good I've been
probably respecting my opinion I respect
it down guys looks like midnight it's
1049 yeah but everyone needs to work
tomorrow except tahina
except for Dana and you yeah my next day
of work is on Thursday is on Thursday
yeah PlayStation Bank oh I don't want to
do that I was just gonna leave it off
actually no I turned it back on oh you
do what the [ __ ] oh you press the button
with the button yeah there's buttons
button who's got the button it's me man
Joey keeps sending me selfies of him in
the shower okay that's hey Xavier that's
a bit much belt on line pal oh yeah
respect five dollars a dreamer Xavier
I'll keep talking to you but a pretty
shirt wasted $50 bullying over a game I
gave you nine months ago you can't keep
doing this you ginger Oh God see ginger
is in the chicken here's how you get
somebody to do something that you want
them to do just call them names you
ginger ass [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
you shrimp dick limp [ __ ] commie Pig
hate insomnia coming their way
is there a way that I could put a plug
in my brain and literally inject my
consciousness into spider-man what was
your reaction to I don't want to go mr.
stark what was my I I thought it was
great
yeah good job come home that was
apparently no that's pretty cool I think
improvised is a strong word sure okay
but I mean like that's what I'm saying
is that
that's what all those articles keep
saying is like that scene was improvised
because they think it like makes it more
impressive that way well I mean I think
I'm panning into the role something
super simple then the ads is line
I think improvised is a strong word I
think the correct word would probably be
it's like it's like you're on set and
you're doing machine and you're like
this this doesn't feel right can I try
something right yeah and there's you a
lot of actors do and then you try it and
then maybe you workshop it a little bit
you think they're over selling it yes
okay that's very but yeah it's still
super cool oh man
the explosive gamer uh hey Xavier what
do you add it your videos with love love
you love you love you
Sony Vegas movie studio HD platinum
version 11 I almost burnt but I didn't
thank you what do you think of the new
Spider recited made by the same people
who have made that fantastic beautiful
piece
Captain Underpants hey man that movie
actually like the first thing I said
about that movie regardless of what it
like writes like it looks pretty yeah
yeah it looks great it looks it looks
real pretty
is it working yet it's all black then
it's more like thing we're like funk oh
there we go
hey the game is tiny look at that - I
fixed it he did fix it Congrats I did it
so as Webber shadows your favorite games
area I'm seeing retrospectives in the
wild oh I'm sorry
this and ultimate spider-man well
they're not my favorites they're the
ones that I just think objectively get
the closest to being the best spider-man
games the spider is my favorite - to be
fair that was like I have a nostalgia
like I do think I think he's right
obviously I personally would put
unstoppable above stop of guys yeah Oh
block plug I would put ultimate
spider-man above this one I think a lot
of the same ideas like shared between
the two games are executed better and
that one right right but it's like
barely edging it out right now of course
all right what's happening again I get
you dude I don't know I felt like just
spider sense I think the story is better
- in economy
I don't know this story is I'm such a
fan of like specific style I guess yeah
the story plays well and obviously
obviously the cell shade in the ultimate
spider-man sometimes this game looks
kind of cel-shaded but it's also how
sometimes because the textures I think
it's the opposite of no it looks comic
book it doesn't look to sell [ __ ] yeah
cel-shaded would be complete outlines of
everything including character that's
why I'm saying she opposite and one of
the things that I think retains like
graphical integrity for games right
exactly and that's like anything so she
ate jet set radio condenser radio future
you know they're just so fascinating to
look at despite the fact that they were
made so long ago right
it's that's what visual this game does
pulled up for me and yeah I mean the
story and ultimate spider-man is better
you know
this story this story is so clunky
and basic really excuse to do cool
spider-man with the Black Sea characters
but other games do that and do it way
better
not even just spider-man games you know
but ultimate spider-man ultimate
spider-man tells a much more focused
story that is like a way more
character-driven and this is just like
this stories like plot things happen is
that better why are people talking about
my girlfriend now I don't know people
just bring people have been bringing
things up that I'm sure they've seen on
your Twitter awhile ago some snap bring
them up like some people have set X X
Xavier [ __ ] food right yeah that's my
rapper name am I am I wrong stayed out
though $5 for a note X creamer I feel
like you're bullying me believe you with
me with money please stop please stop
giving me money dude stop dude he'll
he'll settle down okay a couple of eat
people last it now so and I know you're
hanging already but what was your
opinion on cyberpunk 2077
everyone's gonna think I'm a cynical
[ __ ] because I can't get excited if I
don't see gameplay like you can have
cool CG trailers until the cows come
home but I want to see what the actual
game is gonna look like before I'm gonna
go I want to play that game like there's
so many games that kind of like over the
years wined and dined me with really
cool CG cinematics and then they're not
at all indicative of what the actual
game is like I think one of the big ones
being Dead Island it's just hard for me
to get excited I start true
so I played that game like a while ago
long while ago and it's like one of the
worst games I've ever played and I just
like yesterday Brandon showed me the
trailer for Desmond and I am appalled I
am like like at least watch dogs too for
example that was CG trailer when they
announced that that looked gorgeous and
it was reminiscent of what the world was
gonna be like what the [ __ ] was the Dead
Island trailer dude like that was
insulting that was like comedic it's not
the same thing at all yeah it was an
amazing trailer there's so much emotion
in it dude there was a listing for me I
was telling Brandon about this there's
an actual like whiskey helicopter
character that like asks you to fix his
helicopter he's expecting super racist
meat written it's hilarious
it's just like why is he here would he
like Chrysler my feel about ghosts of
Tsushima I can't tell it apart from like
three other games this year there's so
many games about being like a samurai
warrior or whatever yeah Xavier what do
you think of horror games outside of
superhero games my favorite genres
actually horror games ooh the explosive
gamer 279 with this money buy your first
child of Snickers I will sir thank you
two dollars from a dreamer I'm gonna
stop giving you money okay thank you
okay
dreamer you have officially made me
laugh bullied you bullied Xavier with
money oh man yeah I did it I used to
have to like take 20 minutes on this
[ __ ] part because I was like confused
by this
oh the Wii Wii is [ __ ] abysmal
okay wait was it the same was yes like
visually the same identical really yep
okay that's that's surprising to me
because there's a bunch of games that
they ported oh really that don't do
alright or play anything right it tricks
you cuz you're like wow this looks this
looks great and then you have to do like
motion controls for shooting webs
[Music]
we did it okay now we have we've
unlocked Luke Cage we can now he's he's
our summon attack because this is
turn-based combat so it's 11:00 p.m.
where we are 10:59 Dalton says I played
this on the Wii Dalton I'm sorry
are you okay Xavier cosplay is a nerd
ginger oh you mean Evan florica and a
red wig web of shadows looks the same on
the way wow that's that's super
impressive honestly well someone said it
looks completely different I'm like no
it looks the same I'm lighting the only
differences nap game has alternate skins
right after hi me and my friend are
working on a comic want to check it out
no need for sleep two dollars might be
thank you no need I believe I recognized
him in the disco what am i doing right
now I guess the textures look like are
slightly worse not sure you know was a
really good use of the wheeze like kind
of worse graphics but trying to poor
game was like the Ghostbusters game
because on the ps3 and xbox the graphics
looked kind of like hyper realistic like
they tried to look like the movies but
on the Wii it was the same game just
with this really cartoony style that was
reminiscent of the animated series and
it really really worked
yeah and it was like essentially the
same game just retexture that like these
like cartoony like cel-shaded looking
models in areas and it just it was fine
hey guys I'm gonna ask a really weird
really out there question just in your
mind did you think edgy edgy like
hilariously edgy videogames what'd you
think
top your head whatever game comes to my
infamous and first one yeah yeah okay
that's fair baby anything what was the
question okay reward reward immediately
over the top edgy what do you think off
the top first game hatred hatred hatred
isn't comedic fun I like edgy do you
know how do you go Batman Lego Batman
you think that one no I was too mean to
me okay here's mine Shadow the Hedgehog
oh yes oh yeah forget about that game
that game is the pinnacle of like hey
lovers in the stream who decided to
private message my girlfriend on Twitter
and say that you're glad she's not here
go [ __ ] yourself or you know yeah I know
who it was she told me I'm it's the same
guy he has the same username and he was
saying [ __ ] earlier yeah [ __ ] off you
could just like big brain dude big brain
yeah big brain acknowledge what a [ __ ] I
have to sit I have this same you see and
I'm gonna go get it go bully this person
and then come back secret
big secret boy I'm glad you got in the
stream wow that was insulting oh hey I'm
glad you're not there right now it was
it was that Ghost
you already Mason I are I think you
already I think you already actually
muted him a little while ago
900 IQ gameplay crispy Nick ghost
el-banna wall
yeah he's got it don't worry about it
alright let the moderate or moderate
don't worry about it too much
Xavier has the Incredible Hulk review
going it's not going right now and he'll
go back to it later he said that earlier
I'll try to not react questions mister
knows that play The Incredibles on ps2
was that the one with what Thunder
Underminer yeah there was yeah there was
never played it the main Incredibles
game which for some reason was t14
because it was so violent and then there
is the similar one that was like the
co-op one which was rising oh yeah
frozen
I also the occasional
version on Incredibles I played that
game up so many times I heard about that
one actually it's so good yeah yeah
black cat or Mary Jane um yes sorry yes
not whichever one whichever ones a
better actress along the by Xavier house
contest of slashers going ha ha ha ha
all right next question
alright next question are you drawing
issue 6 yes he's doing that I'm making a
comeback
wait where compression shorts when you
don't write I okay I have actually fixed
the Bulge problem with my cosplay I
haven't taken any pictures of it yet but
I I the cup I have is attached to
compressions shorts so I removed the cup
and then put in a couple layers of felt
and then underwear on top of that and it
makes the bulge like nigh invisible it's
amazing it's it's really good Xavier was
I was a comic I am at comic-con right
now this is still comic-con and it
hasn't stopped we brought it here we
brought it home and we own comic-con
just the Denver one I am calm thoughts
on spider-man III stuff that's alright
well watching some of that stuff it's
not so okay we've gotten how many
minutes into the stream we should
probably mention it now it's been a
while so so Xavier like has been talking
to us about what he thinks about the new
spider-man game and it's it's not that
he hates it it's that it's all that's
he's thought about for a while right so
like he's got a new opinion of it than
before if that makes sense okay I want
to preface this with I am NOT talking
about the Spidey squad every time I say
people on the internet everyone for some
reason thinks it's the Spidey squad
specifically when I'm or just mean my
fan base which yes has quite a big
overlap with the Spidey squad but
they're not synonymous nor is the fan
base for the game exclusively the Spidey
squad like
but get that out of your head but
imagine if a legion of people tell you
once a day every day for two years
actually not even once a day more like
three three or four times I got three or
four times that you should be excited
for something and you're wrong if you
aren't if you have anything that you
think isn't perfect about it or concerns
or comments or questions they'll call
you a hater or say you're wrong and like
scold you for having the wrong opinion
imagine if that happened every day for
two years would you still be excited
with it so like that makes perfect sense
I don't know it makes sense to me that
you'd be exhausted I was exhausted after
first like three weeks yeah you weren't
even I thought you weren't even on the
same grunt either so I get it though
like comes out as long as I can yeah
like I'm gonna play it probably I mean
it so but like what's especially
frustrating and disheartening is when
you spend like three months working on a
video right like three months like you
work on like four or five hours a day
every day whenever you can like as soon
as you get home from school you're
working on it until you go to bed you'd
put in all these long hours on the
weekend you post this video and you feel
like it's the greatest video you've ever
done and you're super proud of it and
then all the comments are people going
hey when are you gonna do another video
about spider-man ps4 it's like hey maybe
maybe comment on the thing that I just
put all this work into and really like
and you know was really proud of like
you know did you like the video that
you're commenting on yeah I know did you
enjoy it
rip did I do a good job I don't know I
can't tell everyone's asking me to just
do something else do something else like
I'm not mad anymore that's I'm not angry
I'm just tired right if I were to
describe my feelings on it it's just
this noise
big size from big boy so what the I like
that you just [ __ ] rock slide what is
happening is do they have water towers
like this is this did this spawn wrong
no is this spider-man 3 which is also
underrated no just modeled into the 40
Hey Xavier when do we get the next
subject to change I'll edit it this week
after Brandon goes home which is
tomorrow morning it's a video where
David makes me in [ __ ] Kyle reads
sonic erotic fan fiction and I want to
die the whole time at one point I get so
upset by the the birth giving scene in
that fanfic that I leave the room for a
little while and let them keep reading
it yeah so look forward to that word to
the birth to BC look forward to that
[ __ ] stay tuned David specifically
planned it so that because like we said
like every fourth podcast would be on my
channel so people don't forget it exists
cuz no one subscribes to him that's
actually what he said I'm not being
hyperbolic he he was like alright for
the next one we should have Kyle on read
fanfiction again and I was like alright
wait a second isn't that the one going
on my channel he said oh is it
I didn't notice and I said you [ __ ]
[ __ ] Xavier Xavier
I got mean Xavier I just figured it out
dude but this is how you solve your you
know your existential problems about
your channel you just become a sonic
erotica Channel
what I feel like I know no dude think
about it dude there's a good whole niche
market there they are not even tapping
into worst part is that it's growing
less in each by the day God hey you
think spider-man has big fan base dude
you have no idea how many viewers
spider-man's penis gets these do live
streams yeah dude well maybe we could do
that for him just for him alright let me
try and get a quick shot this is
Adrienne's dick livestream hold on
someone is asking me a passion there's
gonna sit here a carrot spider-man's
dick how thick is the thick silver
someone was asking me if you should like
ask out a girl I think do it do it yes
and then don't these yes
if something happens I told this girl
that I want to be serious with her well
like I don't know your circumstances and
like what exactly is going on with you
two
because because I'm a guy on the
internet who makes spider-man videos but
um as far as only spider-man but I've
never made another video now bought a
Punisher animated story questioner sure
I could probably do that 12 pants for
Brandon I don't know what for but 12
points yeah I'm like good terms and you
know you should ask her if she's looking
for a serious relationship Jesus wine if
she's not then I don't know if you
should ask yeah I mean going going into
something like wanted to get a serious
relationship out of it
you gotta make sure that's both your
goal right why is one of you wasting
your time can't be a one set oh hello
well if my girlfriend heard that she'd
like oh hey Natasha are you watching
this probably not
ah she doesn't care yeah but on things
I'm dead you haven't seen her in a week
oh [ __ ]
god I didn't go to Colorado to hang out
with a youtuber he just died according
to everyone in my life oh you're gonna
go visit a friend that's a guy what is
he gay is he
are you gay together are you gonna [ __ ]
him my dad asked me that day that I left
like an hour before he left for the
airport and he was like so is he gay are
you gay and I was like yeah dad we're
day together this is how I come out how
does that fighter man hide a boner
well Xavier he totally just figured that
out he doesn't let's go Shazaam dude yo
MJ check it for parts of his body fly
I'm gonna hold off from saying a lot of
dumb things that I want to say because I
know I can make Brandon love me more if
I if I show some restraint just once
thank you just once proud of you said
anyway Joey thanks for that one fan art
oh I was up to playing smash 5 right
[ __ ] bro you got specified you got
smashed by right darkness yes three
Brandon and I found your plate it is
objectively better than any of these it
is comedic it is so good I think the
most overpowered characters Meimei if
you remember cook food Panda 3 that one
girl that kind of flirts with PO for
like two minutes she's in the game for
no reason
blowing kisses and flying on a cloud oh
I'm quickly realizing that this is kind
of not a good game to stream well you're
not doing the thing that you should be
doing well it's okay cuz people are here
to listen to it you're just you're just
swinging around knocking what I did it's
like what there's nothing happening
there's nothing oh yeah cuz fortnight's
so much better it is objectively for
tonight is a better game to stream in
what okay because things are happening
and watching people do
things that are difficult to do is also
objectively better any sort of remotely
East sports related game will will have
that I say that with for tonight because
for tonight is not an esport and go get
the token
yeah the tokens more important than
anything else hey Xavier High Pass Tori
Candice [ __ ] controller
what are you David I'm blocky does
everyone remember when I got really
pissed off at David cuz he broke my ps4
controller cuz he doesn't know how to
hold a controller and he just grips it
so hard that it cracked the plastic I
was like how the circle button was
broken and then magically fixed itself
oh yeah the button it like stuck in
every time he pressed it and then I left
it alone for like several weeks and then
it was fine again hey you know what
would make you play spider-man ps4
yo ginger what do you think of the venom
trailer and the venom look itself it's
okay it's okay yeah I think I look cool
I guess like the CGI could be better but
I know it's a trailer and it's still
early but uh I guess in terms of like
what do I think of the dot did design I
like it it's pretty pretty classic oh
look I did the thing the movies dialogue
sounds a little choppy choppy and bad
but I'm hoping that's because it's a
trailer you work for an evil person is
that a threat why would we do that why
would we do that we can do whatever we
want do we have an understanding sounds
like [ __ ]
good writing would win moon night with a
Hello Kitty PEZ dispenser or rootin
tootin Rasputin with a SAM as hand
cannon
well that was funnier the first six
times you typed it in chat
ouch bro be a cynical [ __ ] just be
shitty to everyone on your [ __ ]
stream react reacts on Xavier you're the
best ginger no I'm not my dad Conan
O'Brien I hope you know that skip
Westcott never got red cards it's canon
to me it's so bad no you didn't get red
cotton so yes it's it's canon to
everyone do a Godzilla video okay you
won't be fun sir you shouldn't Godzilla
and then watch Evangelion and then
realize how bad in that village
no shut up king Godzilla's rad I'm sure
it is - like a million people literally
everyone I watched it with loved it
I thought ok I watched it with like 10
people the other day and we are on a
great time we watched together didn't we
forever yeah yeah well you st. Brendan
if I never did a Godzilla video my
entire you don't do a Godzilla video but
also have to do a mendoza video I just
assumed you hadn't read it damn no I
feel bad dude no I'm just giving you
[ __ ] don't worry about it you're fine
don't don't actually think I'm mad at
anyone except that [ __ ] that ghost
guy who again things have been buggin I
do yeah go find that guy's Twitter and
yelling don't do that I'm just kidding
don't [ __ ] do that everyone go on
Evan fallar cos Twitter
no you are not Xavier
you're not Xavier go what you're not a
saviour who are you that is such a weird
and non-threatening thing to tick you're
not Xavier who are you also okay I
haven't mentioned this at all but I love
the fact that like you
like Webb's whipping in the air like
using crazy amounts of momentum to kick
the dogs but the thugs still try to
fistfight you I'm gonna get him you
literally fly that ridiculous momentum
by whipping to their chest and there's a
zero time and then sometimes they do if
you don't counter you just like [ __ ]
fly back this time I'm gonna get I'm
gonna be the one thug who finally beats
Batman and hand-to-hand yeah they are
using a lot of inside jokes sorry lads I
just kind of assumed everyone knew that
guy yeah but I mean after your this yeah
why is Xavier I'm really glad that
they're all standing in just a evenly
spaced line thank you everyone for not
standing right next to each other even
though I could still do it it would be
easier if you stood next to each other
actually we're just trying to run away
from you they're scary you did it jump
two dollars okay that's your own no one
asked you to pick me that dreamers sent
him the game and donated a total of 32
dollars just spend my money yeah all
right
Josh get on that all right right now fan
art of me and Evan pole are just like
the same thing fighting with our tongue
I kind of really want to write them
goddamn is bring the deal right like a
super detailed fanfic oh god yeah let's
not
I'm sorry play Devil May Cry no but Josh
does on my ps4 for two days straight
yeah it's it was actually a lot of fun
until I got really mad at it and it was
ridiculous the boss designs kind of made
me bad and then I realized later that
some of it was just straight-up my fault
for being really bad the game but some
of the designs are like hey there is no
clear way to do anything that's going on
but do it and you're like okay what's my
objective I remember that time dr. doom
was a bigot to Luke Cage and got his ass
kicked over $200 and Luke Cage is like
where's my money honey and he broke into
Latveria just for 200 bucks
that guy's [ __ ] dead that you killed
him just swing the key this swing kick
mechanic is the greatest for murdering
people
that guy's fine fine oh I need to show
you guys the coger in the steel video
oh my god I put it pull it up on the
street if I were you
no I'm not pulling random weird [ __ ] up
on it's so funny top 10 reasons why
every game is God of War no but all
right I'll mute it but okay so just
imagine if venom was Aries okay so
that's this is the oh that [ __ ] it's
a kilogram of Steve what's heavier the
kilogram is steel or kilogram or feather
[Applause]
[Music]
dude comes on the screen know what you
mean they're both the kilogram but steel
this heavy other feathers
Xavier are you a Spider Man channel a
Deadpool channel a shitpost channel
never classified in a few years I've
been watching you be a blank channel I
think that's the joke he's Josh are
traps gay don't [ __ ] start this again
I love that that code on it's just every
time every time I don't even understand
like I have nothing there's no like
actual reasoning behind my opinion on
that except for one video that's like
not even good evidence here I'll send it
I'm on my pardon the interruption
everyone goes subscribe to Josh's
YouTube channel again a post I'll post a
video someday that's the image that
makes me laugh he's like he's got two
people explaining like kilogram of Steel
at left in the feathers of reason but
there's so many feathers on the right
that's cheatin everyone's asking million
crap Sergei don't worry guys they are
I remember this mission kind of be hard
at first we thought oh just like silly
and formulaic you just keep bashing them
in cars I also like how this mechanic is
never useful again ever
are you are you watching the stream
sorry I've said it now it's a move so I
just exploded them with people in it
like no murdering soulmates buying
spider-man's never killed anyone except
that girl from the Wolverine process
look make me a mod for my trap Sergei
its diligent well he's not I'm not
actually gonna argue gender politics
because this doesn't actually argue them
with this link
I won't let me send any links [ __ ] I
need to make you a mod for that oh my
god just look up traps or gay just just
please make me a mod thanks everyone for
coming to my my TED talk about why traps
are gay my video essay traps my video
because it has no bearing on on my
opinion it's just what the video is so
[ __ ] funny spider-man
it was a trap whatever the falaqa still
be so attractive then these become
salute everyone ask Evan full arc oh
he's gonna get his cap mom infinite Josh
I would like to apologize for what would
you do did you okay it's okay pal I
can't wait till I find out that he did
something a whole exam page live here
are you gonna do a boy waiting for spike
am I gonna do a moan echoes I hope
spider-man comes back I have no one to
talk I miss him so much
I really just want to stroke his mass
god damn I miss spider
I [ __ ] hate my life right now kissing
through his mass I just wanna just want
to slurp on that fabric what a smooch
involves everyone tell Evan abides
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite already like
you justify my party
yes our traps the bomb squad also was
brown-skinned that's it yeah that's why
I don't even look round what do you do
I'm gonna swing kick these [ __ ]
Xavier what are your thoughts I'm Josh
he's pretty cool and I wish he was my
dad Josh Keaton is such a handsome man I
wish I could I wish he was an electro
and he was spider-man pull the ligament
in my leg today the stream is more
painful oh wow geez why are you watching
it turn it off [ __ ] you save yourself
some trouble but [ __ ] is that guy did
you just take off your belt
oh yeah it's alright okay get to all
those dudes I donate $1,000 in chat and
I'll strip all the money if we reach our
$1,000 goal Brandon with script did I
say I was gonna do that every $50 trap
or a lesbian I don't know I was asking
my girlfriend the other day if I could
borrow some of her skirts and she was
yeah yeah yeah dude yeah you want to say
that on the Internet hey guys they can't
tell what we do and what isn't a joke
I'm a trap I'm dressed in a raven
cosplay right now that's what that Raven
cosplays for its freaky it's not really
all along you see that purple wig that's
mommy's gonna wear the spider yeah
that's what its gonna be
mr. eclipse you ever watch Guyver yeah i
watch guy ever I remember being like
kind of grossed out by it as a little
kid because there's some kind of like
weird body horror gore stuff in there
macGruber macGruber
he did what vane did to Batman
but without his feet hey but we Ahmad I
don't need to be a mom
I don't type a comment in the all guys
head stand that was he saying how look
on the bridge bro sick bro that's
vertical plank you got my neck muscles
vertical thanks dude Luke Cage has even
stronger of a neck than I do which is
known at all holy dude Luke Cage is a
whole tour ok type a thing in here so I
can promote you just say what's your
channel name Josh here you can control
this conversation dangerous he just said
daddy daddy okay here we go I'm gonna
like alligator I like skipping through
it so it's just yeah there you go yeah
yeah now you're a mod I promoted Josh
they got remote Josh promote Josh to
Godzilla nobody it's all oh come on guy
yeah what if Josh starts making videos
he becomes more successful than any of
us oh my god I'll do someone made that
joke about me and like 9th grade and
then he started really resenting me for
it oh that sucks
cuz we all had YouTube channels and all
had aspirations of getting like a couple
thousand subs and like really making it
and all of them stayed at like 25 except
me and it started to cause like some
problems where he started getting angry
at me and every time I would talk about
my youtube channel he would like a room
it felt bad guys it's called being petty
that's all they're called high school
that guy was like actually really cool
cool before that and I'm really sad that
that happened cuz I want I was like I
usually bumping really low being his
friend oh my god I'm sad this just looks
like Chicago every city looks like every
other city no but like New York all now
New York streets are so much more
congested
I'm gonna go check out my channel also
this is the thing that I meant to post
this is a video that performs my you got
to go to the Park Ave neighborhood and
[ __ ] thoughts on Howard Mackie isn't
that the guy playing Falcon isn't he
like a weirdo who's like super Pearl
Marvel anti DC and always like stroking
off about how great their movies are
it's like his NWA crisp yeah threatening
me by eating my ass geez I do a
daredevil Cosme I love more than I'll
eat your ass I might I got a hair right
so much is happening stop self promoting
yourself to yourself you guys stream
etiquette don't talk over each other oh
sorry go swing swing kick those [ __ ]
I've done movie is that a thing the
whole one hot one the none movie I
didn't know there was a movie based on a
nun preheat the oven 250 to 350 hey
Xavier you Geico caveman haired Beast
what you got in mind for your next
cosplay video I make cosplay videos
inspired by you I hope you can check my
stuff out and stay stay being you dude
trap Zillah Zillah oh man what if trap
Zilla caught on and then peace sir
there's already fan art of me as a girl
and now there's just gonna be more yeah
Josh tell Brandon about that I'll cook
him - josh is coming Oh Brendan yeah oh
my god my channel my channel is sentient
that's his YouTube channel that's funny
hey those guys I swear to god go to bed
those guys stop it go to bed
cosplay Zulu Kate no it's fine it's just
my channel is super disobedient is
paying $60 for [ __ ] let's go to bed
channel you're grounded
no more podcast for a week hey Xavier
cavil can I have a wow wow wow wow wow
oh you like a Owen Wilson while that
Will Smith yeah yeah Will Smith is
painted on that wall I'm saying be there
or be square and have a little go to bed
channel go to bed or you're grounded
mister gang member look like this is a
game he looks down this version of
spider-man looking at all so how [ __ ]
tall are some of these guys thank you I
don't expire my looks at that tall he
looks tall I go stand next to an NPC I
guess there's an ultimate spider-man
your short little baby
all those guys not the channel oh look
at all these JPEGs citizens disappearing
there's no one around
we are your dad's and oh look there's
one go stand next to me Savior I'm
trying to parent my channel right now
can you do it then I was choking me and
quietly
Joshi sound like Xavier if he was
[Laughter]
personality traits really we both like
trash I just wanted everyone to know how
much you like traps yeah what she loved
y'all are streaming the whole game right
yeah this [ __ ] 19 hour game just like
we did for spider-man the stream works I
think we'll be done around midnight yeah
maybe midnight 30 around that's my
favorite toys better or kids see ghosts
you guys have any opinions on uh neither
those albums ah that's what I thought
all right kids see ghosts to me was a
little better than oh my gf is not a
crab shine so we'll never make sense
that way it was pretty fun I think major
thank you
damn it I'm talking it's not your scream
this hey why is it walking on it's so
annoying just do it look at it I like
though there's a D shape in a map [ __ ]
dude I can take it up big all these guys
I don't know audio so I'm just seeing me
yell at a couple of thugs walking out of
the building like he's really unhappy
with with their service and then like
some dude appears with a sniper rifle
on-screen oh man people don't know
sarcasm so they're actually asking me if
I like like crabs now cuz y'all are a
bunch of it's well when people ask me if
I don't know how to spell my name
because of a joke in a video and they're
they're don't have any irony sometimes I
gotta get a little upset
no that's when you lean in Jenin even
harder yeah I'd never learned how to
spell my name I dropped out of school in
kindergarten yeah I'm too smart for it
that's actually what they called me big
brain everyone's doing a whole bit about
how Luke Cage walked in a room after
those renowned dogs gave and Logan
pronounced wrong yeah I probably
pronounced it twice me hey did you know
it is the only way to say it because
last name did you know did you know that
characters being gay is hilarious did
you know that making a joke about a guy
receiving a [ __ ] is hilarious I
laughed so hard hey guys
yes two men engaging in sexual
intercourse
man if you guys could see Brandon's face
right the most genuine laugh okay I got
such purple face right now because it
man has been choking me anyhow all right
save your thoughts on spider-verse it
looks really cool alright okay I don't
know what you people want from me I just
want to go home they want to
frame-by-frame analysis seems like the
emoji any single women in this chat
spider Jake please you do not go to
livestream chats to pick up girlfriends
that does know let him try let him try
let me try and post updates that's a
very funny inside joke three people are
gonna get that out of them I know my
meeting terms with right now oh okay
hold on you remember that [ __ ] meme
picture of Piper Perry on the couch with
the the several black guys what do you
see your names I don't know
whenever I do it all the time with
everyone I like whatever spider-man is
standing that said does that we need to
isolate that clip I'm saying that
wherever spider-man is standing next to
these guys it looks like the Hatley they
were trying to so tiny next to all these
black dudes so I did not mean to press
that dammit too late now Wow good job
you did it
I feel like all the traps are trying to
date spider Jake now I mean he brought
it on himself to save your thoughts on
getting the LD asked question there
wasn't that wasn't save your thoughts on
getting repeatedly and tried asking that
earlier Wilson Fisk
well my thoughts are that on the fiscal
building take a look around and spawn
again in the morning what's my life I
would actually go straight for Josh
please read this exam here I have
nothing left to live for says Alex you
know that always works
hi Alex Xavier has he ever done the
voice acting well I've done a couple of
videos maybe other people's videos
sometimes but not really like
professional voice acting although I
would like to if there was any kind of
chance I could be that guy that gains 24
donated $2 Evan full arc as a trap wall
love you AJ here I know I give Evan
florica a huge amount of [ __ ] but don't
actually think that I hate him I just
like I just like bullying him a little
it's endearing it's it's out of love
okay don't actually be me doing mmm-hmm
I was a silly child he's a sweet he's a
sweet boy yes sweet boy Josh waiting the
perfect amount of time and then say yeah
is my favorite [ __ ] yeah yeah cuz it
makes me when you're like an idiot every
time it's no better when the bits over
you just you go yeah yeah okay I guess
I'm reviving this now it makes me feel
like an idiot
what just happened well no I stubbed my
toe
not just the the spider-man equivalent
like stepping on a Lego see if you can
you hook me up with Josh I like his a
swell dreamer there's a lot no don't
acknowledge him why I was sufficiently
not $72 a half
if they send me money I have your hope
insomniac games will love me now I'm
sorry I hate you but I love you
what's ever gonna [ __ ] do in all these
games he's gonna make videos about why
you shouldn't go to college I'm so
worried about him they're just gonna
make a video on why he's gonna do a
spider-man ps4 retrospective hey guys
remember I remember when I reviewed this
ten years ago that's ten years from now
I'm gonna review it again with my new
tastes Xavier was wit already like David
is with Xavier it's exactly that cuz
David just treats me like [ __ ] all the
time
that's awful so accurate radioactive
replay with Brandon here spider baby
cats I play came out two weeks ago I'm
making a new review to like address my
new tastes and differences that
everything that changed it's still
really good I still jerk off to it
I wish ever knew who I was so I was a
lot I'm allowed to believe him instead
of making this seem like I'm just kind
of insult right Evan I'm sorry I don't
follow you on twitter anymore it's just
your Twitter was annoying me but I think
that you are a nice human no ill-will
you mean no harm
despite the fact that you caused it
constantly
no Alex to me Alex does harm to me wait
this is important
Alex says now Josh and Xavier have
finally read one of my comments I feel
like a complete idiot perfect I like
about Black Cats stops and waits for me
to follow her do not let my cat escaped
everyone type Alex is a stupid
photograph' a stop stop they don't build
an F n OG no it r th I'm sorry racists
derpy
Alex you're not stupid Snyder you're a
wonderful daughter don't let her escape
she sees you of [ __ ] like are you
shooting wipes directly onto her and
it's not affecting her momentum at all
this is a really easy chase and
sometimes you can actually get ahead of
her cuz you're gonna [ __ ] like this like
oh she's wearing a Deadpool belt buckle
look at it during the cutscene I swear
to god it's the Deadpool logo just what
are you guys I really like that you
could like web-swing off of her she's
like flying just like the helicopter in
spider-man 2 yeah I like the idea of her
running around on the sidewalk with him
just dragging along like that scene in
homecoming just going half I stole this
joke from him well yeah yes yeah my
friend always used to do that in college
like we just beat everyone would be
doing stuff and like thank you for
stopping me slides up to the building
baby I know it's just I hadn't seen it
that tenuous a stressor how you doing
but some alright see you later okay
again explain this for posterity Xavier
someone who hates you a lot of money to
say the n-word
whenever my friend okay never be one of
the three thousand dollars on video
everyone be silent cuz know who laugh at
the bad joke to go rock yeah just to
make it funny just to make everyone
laugh so it's all him it's it's still
good me I love you Colin keep doing it
with everything I say and it makes me
feel like an idiot and I will I don't
want to talk anymore alright yeah yeah
god damn it yeah what do I bring you
people here only babies emasculate
you're that kid on the on the playground
that's like oh man I hate when people
steal my hat and then it's like you just
told every bully on the playground what
to do with your ad I knew that kid you
know I was that good I was to learn for
my widow whose kid named Joseph I think
I was like masochistic or something I
was never cry on purpose again some
other someone else in tablets okay yeah
no okay really funny story and we always
got into a fight with him on recess like
really like a long time in a circle
around it yeah let me flip it you II and
he what we kicked him in the dick once I
was doing bait and uh what'd he call it
teacher was really unhappy with us
if you cry oh my god that's so psycho
dude oh my god I just kind of pull I
literally just went sociopathic Bernese
Oh God that's a Criminal Minds origin
story she able to survive these well
[ __ ] I'm really sorry
well it's green Goblin's here someone
said good story hey Brandon laughed and
I laughed so okay go [ __ ]
good super aggro you gotta [ __ ] guys
we're gonna go hang out the best
character in the game [ __ ] spider-man
shut up stop [ __ ] doing man I'm gonna
kick your head you know that I can beat
you in a fight yeah yeah yeah let's do
it do this so I can try it let's go yeah
yeah right now okay playing spider-man
ghetto you up nerd I'm cool Oh you ease
the whole thing whole thing that that
line was pretty good yeah you know I
remember being a lot funnier probably Oh
God okay get a web cam you sexy man I
don't know if my computer can handle all
of running a webcam on top of everything
else so that's dumb because you can okay
you're just gonna everyone's got to deal
with extremely low res every follicle of
no be you know it just it just fits his
eyebrows his eyes his nose his mouth and
his chin in the shot that's it hey guys
what's up its we're back with another
irradiated and your active look it's a
run up and down the stairs a couple
times so you're like super out of breath
[Music]
hey it's my true love's that beyblade
yeah it's my dad dude you let it rip get
out of there so I can hug you and
hotcake that moon night dancer night
shut up dim whoa five dollars dividuals
I have no money but I love your channel
man keep up the amazing content
notification squad yes I said that on
ironically hey that's okay thank you for
sending money so we love you we
appreciate your look guys alright let's
dance yeah they they just they just play
video games is it called retro replay
yes marques actually Troy Baker it's his
greatest performance there so they're
like the kings due to their such and
once Steve bloom to be there just to
complete it why is she over here yeah
Steve bloom is the unsung hero of those
guys like barely 30k views on these
videos how this is the best black cat
what are you doing over there
haven't even seen it yet I'll watch it
with pizzas just like sex even when it's
bad makes you cry I'm reading this is
golden basement yes honey aren't you
like 50 now yeah yeah she's my favorite
blue there's one that's way more cute
where she holds you down on the ground
like pings your arms and then like
really yeah yeah Catwoman in the arcade
games where she like goes in for the
kiss takes the dude - it's like sticks
your face on his face buddy's fat she
like puts her tongue in the fabric thank
your channel I love you Channel
goodnight sweat brains sweat tonight
fresh bread they're not so Fresh Prince
dude my son is the freshest Prince dude
remember that time black cat proposed to
Peter you
and then she was actually just a way of
her [ __ ] with him so that she could
slit his Achilles tendon and run away is
the only way to like you know like that
yeah we'll stop she did the easiest way
that's like outsmart his spider sense is
to just distract it one time that's like
saying weird flirty [ __ ] in the
headphones right now I can hear it's
like I missed playing with my spidey man
he's just punching the [ __ ] out of her
they've never had a fight like this I
don't know why this is in the game kick
your ass I love that that black suit
move reaches backhander like across the
[ __ ] man Wow
gets better better took a wine you know
what why don't you kiss her huh what No
maybe counter-attack sexist no would be
ready if I did it yeah but it's fine
when she does it it's fine when she
force Josh's women are not objects okay
spider-man spider-man is very much an
object insomniac told us that if she
breathes what what what are you
referencing I'm not gonna say what was
that tell me after Street okay all right
bye gap of death
hold on hit throw a car at her cuz I
hate her somewhere apparently you're not
black cat look this is me breaking up
with you Peter Parker said $10 this is
for hitting black cat around more than a
pink pin love interest Oh God well in
the old name universe it was like a
robbery
yeah and the ultimate university was way
worse yeah it was like not even like in
like a superhero context it was just sad
I'm just gonna keep webbing striking
this man until I feel good about myself
it's just like you continue keeping out
of context and make it sound bad hey
that time Spiderman killed that lady
here to hear about that time Superman
bludgeoned his pregnant wife to death
and was the direct reason that's yeah he
did do that [ __ ] what injustice is rough
oh yeah it is isn't it
but see I took it out of the context of
Joker tricking you can't get me out get
me I'll got you can make anyone sound
like an [ __ ] who just remove context
that time Brandon punch me please she's
like let's you get up after it she no
longer wishes to sex you know dope
that's how she does it you know what's
really dumb at all of dance lots use of
black cat okay yes but nah I'm not done
so much weird like imagine fighting
spider-man and he keeps switching
costumes
the fight like arbitrarily he's just
like I have the black suit on now
imagine how confusing and weird oh man
and this is my favorite QTE in any game
ever because if you [ __ ] it up it's
pretty stupid and it's almost at the
level of that one in spider-man 3 by
this game's internal logic the black
suit is on all the time alright yes but
he makes the conscious decision when
he's wearing the red and blue suit to
not be ultra violent hey what's up how
you doing are you okay
[Laughter]
I'm so sorry little one Oh Red Skull is
proud of me this is the best one ready
I'm gonna savor just like Glenn both
scream at the same time I like your dead
pool party on Gwen's death and wasps in
the ultimate universe wasp is the
ultimate comic book waifu and if you
disagree you're wrong
and also I'm glad she died because I
don't like one
hey spider-man spider
get off me creep perv gross slam don't
touch me yo don't touch me I'm in the
big spins him down and starts furiously
straddling his talk while slapping and
repeatedly scratching him in the nipples
[ __ ] you you pervert black cats just the
shitty backwards feminist oh she's like
the bad feminist
oh no thanks dance lon thanks Dan I bet
Dan Slott would do that he like that's
so funny I don't think they realize how
many times you did you messed it up on
purpose
you know now a couple of them on purpose
the other what times were cuz I was
laughing so hard I couldn't do it good
night Mason he's going to bed what's
going on alright I'm the only mod that's
awake watching Ahmad I don't know watch
me mod watch me Naenae what Ken can I
can I just when he reaches over and just
zips it back up a little
can you just you look old it is it's
high up right now you're shaking it's
not turning me on and I just feel
concerned because you're like a hog in
tries to warm her up and he's just like
I'm not turned on alright now this is
just for your benefit I don't want you
to get a cold buckling I can't see it
definitely is
know what's going on okay I don't know
what's going on but this is she's
basically pitching him on let's get
together and then and then like just
[ __ ] crime and each other and he's like
no thanks sorry Felicia I'm moving into
redheads you know it he's like your
pitch and walks out the door while we're
at music plays he's everything yet or
won't either whichever one gets me to
hey Damon guys that's the first time
I've been able to do it so I can i after
hitting the note wrong like 300 times
uh-huh you did it this did I actually
not do it
I couldn't tell I'm sorry you got high
you did yeah yeah because I gotta
because I'm not high no I'm not okay
for people don't understand why those
random [ __ ] spring because I realize
now that's that sounded really [ __ ]
awful
yeah we over the past few days at
Brandon's bottle just took the bottle
away cuz he hates you so I'm trying to
tell something and it slams them
look it's my my boyfriend's not I will
give you your bottle let me know Lucas
hey Thor you guys see ya looks like eat
like one used it to wipe he looks looks
like the inside of the Death Star after
so low he goes through the bathroom he's
just like [ __ ] you know what there's no
magazines I think [ __ ]
just wipe with comic books like I do oh
this is so gross
[Music]
okay what I don't like is that they
didn't get munites personality right in
this because he's telling you to be more
responsible when all he does is get
scolded by the Avengers for being
irresponsible they call him loony Mooney
and they go to great lengths to avoid
him because they think he's a [ __ ]
hero is Spider Man part of the Avengers
yes oh right oh my god he's dead you see
this moon knight doesn't have enough of
a boner for murder you know what they
should do you should kill spider-man off
but it just make it for a while why
just so everyone like like forgets how
like crazy they are about him and then
they can tell genuinely cool stories
again when he comes back yeah like with
what what they're planning to do with
Wolverine after it's stagnated a little
yeah what like what happened with Batman
as well during blackest night yeah yeah
sometimes it's necessary to [ __ ] kill
them all I do a miniseries about Mary
James earth conscious and not like a
like a wonder drawn in an anime style
where everyone's just talking about
their relationship like an actual one
you stop bouncing that bottle off the
seal I have it is super annoying
I have nothing to contribute to this
conversation jhin's I'm so sorry so you
know what it's like to be me ninety
percent of time what are you kidding
almost every conversation that surrounds
you is just [ __ ] you it's like things
that speakers yeah so you're kidding
yeah yeah yeah yeah g-dog yeah yeah [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you too I love you hi friend
yeah yeah hug I can't do that
why too far I can't do that Felicia
can't or won't
same thing either either neither I don't
care just leave me alone
put it Bette put it away stop waving
that thing in my face black cat that's
wrong
what's the most edgy comic you read uh
Batman throw killer that one's a good
contender I would say maybe kick ass too
but the only thing that beats it is
crossed with lost Tesla's crossed has a
scene where a guy stabs another guy with
a knife and then puts his dick in the
hole the boys is not actually that edgy
Logan old man Logan is kind of edgy yeah
but like in all the right ways yeah well
he'll certainly be bad Mark Miller can
do edgy but most of the time good edgy I
have to destroy these wall drills have
you ever tried to pull a heist on a
skyscraper where you have to set up this
giant [ __ ] piece of technology that
takes like 19 men you install and
operate
they were just what the [ __ ] why was
there a car there I'm so confused I
think we've pretty well proven that this
game is pretty buggy yeah that's the
thing about is this you know what this
games like awesome but boy is this game
[ __ ] button this might as well be a
bethesda game yeah okay bye that but
it's professor at this point just a
computer that just craps out games yeah
on Howard they send out a cyborg
Howard is a cyborg from the future
Howard's a [ __ ] synth that man is a
synth and a Hydra agent and a scroll
yeah yeah I'm not even doing it be more
and if I do I just not purpose no Jesus
dude then we can't do the emmys friend
is your V get up if I ever say yeah it's
not intentional
at least at this point I'm sorry I'm
sorry
that was very clearly get up you're fine
yeah walk it off good thing the tailor
asked Billy to move up your little cat
your little brothers I see all taxis
it's New York
that's not New York word yes it is
no one owns a car in New York only taxis
in our town look how [ __ ] empty
traffic is ubers don't exist to you the
world is so Lively look it's spider-man
ps4 I got angry at God and just started
killing everything he loves now get up
you're fine puncher get up puncture yeah
accidentally punch your sibling
they're like country like you're like
roughhousing and then like accidentally
like suplex them through a glass table
and then tell them get up you're fine
it's okay so you don't get in trouble
yeah you ever just accidentally murdered
your girlfriend and then say hey kid
I don't want you to be dead hey kid
don't be dead
I don't want you to be dead I don't want
you to be dead great you ever laugh so
much so what what gosh take over so baby
you don't have a girlfriend basically
save me senpai fell down headfirst
because I wanna kill him and take his
costume cuz it's cooler than mine
hey you guys have been fostering Diego
says $5.00 do you guys are the
collaboration we don't deserve hell you
didn't hear I'm so sorry
we need you hear me that's not we need
to get now is Jacob and Diego in and
then we've got the squad dude the spikes
nobody stuff the spider-man school I've
been shows up he's like hey that's mine
the webhead squadron Peter Parker where
are your tub of vanilla ice cream wait
did we have one last time what no I
don't remember what happenes or what
spider-man 3 is a hybrid Spidey movie
besides homecoming if I kill more
innocent people Moon Knight will love me
what if what if what if Sony actually
made amazing spider-man 3 it would have
been bad the police siren turns off
assume I like doing the first listen do
that what no no it would have been
turned back on worse but the last fight
I had to was terrible I love how the
black suit is dependent on this police
siren and vice versa it's like whatever
there's a black
guy around the Sun is on now I pull up
my gears I got a strange happenings in
cities spider-man behind it that's a big
why didn't they just put a threat her
menace Jonah why did you print this bad
resolution picture don't give Peter
money for this he didn't earn it
this is garbage he should [ __ ] feel
bad Peter your composition sucks in your
camera's low res now dude Peter couldn't
find a picture so we just drew one and
he drew it and minecraft with blocks and
then took a screenshot from really high
up okay what am i doing that's a good
question Xavier what are you doing it's
12 tall make-a-wish night I just wanted
to say hi because I just wanna lick this
hood there windows is a menace Branden
just tried to put his head on my
shoulder but didn't quite make his
mendoza is he a threat or a menace
we were like dizzy I saw someone asked
earlier if I was half Latino and Nolan
he's Filipino I'm Filipino which is like
half Latino half asian
hey what yeah hey hey yeah yeah damn I
don't want to like have conversations
with human being
right it's not that bad I love I want to
die I kiss you with my love's Big Love
give it your work Carl bikinis and I end
see Lenny this is why people think we're
getting this the I need you I need a
thesaurus Big Love sent you're going
keep going full stop I'm a big gay have
some beautiful eggs
Oh Peter Parker's we did it for us Jade
a tub of ice cream well no I don't know
if we have any in the house right now
but because you said that now I'm kind
of hungry
my name is Brandon and I'm here to say
that Xavier and Josh might be really gay
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm doing dabs hey
mom I'm doing dabs over here your
[ __ ] mom calls you and tells me
you're not allowed to come honey are you
doing Dan Colorado mom I'm doing dabs in
here dude I'm doing sick dabs Oh God
no man if you saw my sick dabs doing
what would prosecution no Court would
convict me of these dads
if the dab fits then you must acquit the
fattest ribs taken I had to turn around
see that course correction yeah that is
if you can you can take a rip from this
bong and make it into the shape of a
heart
you can go Oh Jay guys in the
transformers cartoon beast wars they use
the term vaped to like talk about
vaporizing people and it just doesn't
hold up now that's so for every time
they say yeah I got vape by the
predacons it's like oh god [ __ ] this
cartoon changed you there I knocked over
your [ __ ] roof drill Walt a little
microphone some more Brandon please yeah
make sure everyone can hear
sound of you like angrily masturbating
okay it's not quite curious its angrily
I did it I completed the quest hey
Xavier if enough money is donated will
you cut your hair and decide ways
cornrows like a true Osborne goodnight
you love me thank you can I touch you
what will you please get cold okay do I
have to cut my hair to get cornrows I
don't think so I think it's better if
you've longer hair right yeah okay if
someone donates two thousand dollars I
will get cornrows for a day one yeah
yeah well that's how it works that yeah
[ __ ] you I'm setting the rules okay yeah
rotary reverse No else I'll donate the
2000 this is the this is the laws of my
timeline if you'll like it you can
[ __ ] go live in 326 where things are
better schemes yeah man thanks thanks
moon night welcome can I lick your ear
hey stop actually I put the point I love
his hood I want it you're never gonna
sexy like that yes yes two thousand
dollars for Korres and three thousand
for the N word for the someone asked me
if I would say the n-word on stream and
I said if you donate three thousand I'll
consider it
he'll think about it it'll actually go
through his brain but it still could
come out as a big mouth four percent
Caucasian 94% gingers 100% not gay
ten percent virgin I'm gay I'm gay
it means was that Jax yeah this is Jack
Spillman do you know a guy named John
Roos John Romita is in there John Romita
actually do you recognize him
well hold on I got I just noticed
they're talking hang dude Jer did junior
senior died where is he you just told me
I think he did chat answer this question
look at I Pro I am MLG Pro strats now we
only have junior yeah that's fine as
long as the colorist is good you just
got so much worse
yeah are you not entertained Bob's
Burgers like [ __ ] what's your name
what are the kids not the is it the one
that's voiced by a guy that's like the
one that's voiced by their girlfriend
gravity falls no the one that's voiced
by a guy but it's a it's a girl
character yeah it's very weakly now yeah
Tina that's he sound like
[Music]
Peter Parker it's not as probably is
like so you have this zero
oh brother you're Parker's life savings
Peter Parker you needed that to go to
Aunt May's medical bills what are you
doing yeah you're Parker is it poor
because he's like actually struggling
donating screamers dude streamers are so
persuasive bro I just look at this guy
were playing as he loves watching
fortnight's dreams this guy now he likes
watching indie streams
yeah really like stupid indie games
Andrew Garfield probably only plays
indie games like Andrew Garfield is an
indie game like Andrew Garfield
spider-man is like such a hipster and
Deirdre Garfield spider-man has only
listen to bands you've never heard of oh
jerison you're still alive that's good
good for him tell him I said hi with him
dude was that junior junior care Junior
I love you even though no one else does
yeah I'm gonna keep getting momentum so
I can get up here and [ __ ] kick this
guy I did it see how good this game
swinging is is because you can actually
loop around a little bit to get like
extra momentum I love that whenever we
go for night sucks hey gmod sucks oh
yeah but everyone who uses gmod loves it
you know number one they used to make
funny animations on gmod it was a
grammar and it was great when you were
ten but now that you're like twenty it's
not funny anymore are you sure these are
rocks on rocks on rocks off I almost but
you had too much dignity
don't worry I don't have that problem
I'll leave that to you it's my job
[ __ ] idiot I do it so well
well done this may lead us to the source
of kingpins will hey have you seen the
clip of Reggie talking about fortnight I
did that's [ __ ] hilarious Reggie is
always so funny whether intentional or
not it's so good
he just he's like I can't wait until I
see okay guys here's that one mission in
the game I'm sorry about earlier
Brandon I didn't know no no okay all
right okay yeah I used to all right well
you know I can't tell work Karl begin
begins and I end seat Lennie this is why
people think we're gay I can't tell
where spider-man begins and my ass and I
can't tell where Batman Begins pin
supermanned hands well by the way I
showed up at the daily boggle but then
you find out it was a trap guy we're
gonna blow up the courthouse
if this comment is read aloud I will
absorb a full moon night or sorry new
night cosplay tutorial - whoops I missed
it
okay it's just comment is from night
today seems legit all right Dark Knight
Rises it would from night to day how
could that happen that's like how time
works [ __ ] how dare you hey guys the
courthouse is the courthouse we'll all
got the game took over my controls
they're gonna say it or not yet
we'll get this a you get a stuff the
bombs to turn a bolt support out of that
guy's record house
this is all of them okay and then just
linger on that shot wow that was really
delayed butter man cited I'm gonna have
moon night show up and help me because
he'll take care of everything
by killing everyone because I'm too much
of a [ __ ] yeah that's why he doesn't do
it yeah spider means he's not cool we're
getting there hang on put your dicks
away they're all pizza time over there
his own game and we were playing that
right now instead and then Spiderman was
in it and he said Bowman you know I
think that no night's games really well
developed I just think that spider-man
you know me I love anything spider-man
just a 19 year old nerd on YouTube I
love fortnight Doctor Who in anything
spider-man member I'm sweaty squad stew
twitter keeps telling me to follow that
guy and you know it's funny what that
guy is like 90 is the description of a
YouTube thing that I just gave you
applies to so many Twitter accounts all
right ready there's a bomb it's really
funny these got a bomb
thank you you're the you guys are the
only ones I donated I am the bomb squad
for the bomb squad thank you Peter
Parker you are the bomb squad the bomb
squad was within all of us all along now
I'm just gonna let this bond rest on my
back so I can [ __ ] die come on I
don't want to live anymore
tell MJ I said I don't care MJ MJ where
is
MJ wears cage in his search party ah you
were no help should I should I just let
it all end
should this be the end of the story of
people cuz we're about actually okay I
should go walk in no my ball it was
ripped from your back damn it I'll find
more civilians Lola I think my favorite
thing is footage and the bomb came up on
screen out of nowhere my neighbors
started screaming new conversation hose
in and I was saying another sentence and
I stopped take you all with me look look
it's it's Times Square I can finally
fulfill my destiny
look everyone walked towards me because
I'm the good spider-man senior lure them
in they would walk away if I was Baumann
but I'm now Redman so they love me they
love me and I'm gonna punish em for it
anyway thanks for the stream everyone we
had a great time and it's rending it so
rather than sort of god that's it for my
sake Severn we love you we appreciate
you showing up this is fun
it was good thanks to Brandon for
actually being out here this time yeah
instead of making us wait an hour and a
half before he showed up to DC Universe
Online yep yep yep yep thanks Brandon
yeah yeah I know about that inside joke
yeah yeah I just sat on the bat-signal
waiting for him and crying you know I
was there for like two minutes trying to
tell you that I was there and he just
kept talking it sounds like me you could
find it on the stream I was like I am
here and then you left
hahahaha and I was like trying to find
you and I still couldn't find you yeah
same well this is the end of well the
end of the stream we love you guys luck
you bye thanks for the donations you're
all really cool people the patron call
will about we do one on another patron
is anyone busy on Saturday you patreon
man's donate to my patreon and you can
do a voice chat with me and my other
patrons on the discord go check the
discord which I think Mason is gonna
post the link to or if he hasn't or
maybe Josh can post it on and I'll yeah
he probably did the one in the
description for some reason doesn't work
anymore cuz [ __ ] my life
Evan please buy Capcom vs. Marvel
infinity war like I asked you to stop
making me wait you're really blue
balling me on that one buddy I'm getting
I'm getting impatient
I'm gonna start worrying that you don't
actually like me that much
he shelled out money for dinner so let's
do this Evan Evan there's a possibility
he just doesn't like you how much is it
possibility now you as your best friend
I love you and we're gonna move in
together
yeah alright bye mmm